Ein Schauspieler muss immer
die Rolle fühlen, ...
... um die Rolle zu werden.
Ich sage nur: Baby!
So kann man teilweise aus
der Rolle ...
... seiner Behinderung
herausschlüpfen.
Bis zu einem
gewissen Grad.
Was gibt das für
ein Gefühl?
Ein erfülltes Gefühl auf
alle Fälle. Ein Supergefühl.
Das ist wie das Leben.
Ich höre nicht auf, ...
... bis ich auf der Bühne
umkippe und sterbe.
Die einen setzen sich hin
und lernen mit dem Textbuch.
Ganz einfach: Textbuch
vor dir, ...
... zuerst einmal Cola trinken
und dann klappt es.
Eine Schwierigkeit ist, wenn man
lange mit etwas gearbeitet hat,
und dann gibt es eine Änderung,
die man neu speichern muss.
Ich liebe es, Kostüme anzulegen.
Das ist Teil meines Jobs.
Theater ist für mich wie Liebe.
Und ich brauche alles,
was Theater ist.
Wir müssen Überzeugungsarbeit
leisten, dass ...
... Behinderte eben doch
bildungsfähig sind.
Berühmt sein?
Man verdient viel Geld.
Und man kommt raus aus dem Image
'Mensch mit Beeinträchtigung'.